offshore has announced the new price cap
will go up to
3459 pounds
national energy action predicts that
will put 8.2 million people in fuel
poverty from october
it's a huge jump the price cap was
1277 pounds last winter and is currently
set at 1
971 pounds
so let's get more on this i'm joined now
by off gems chief executive jonathan
brielly a very good morning to you
jonathan brealy some really tough news
for people to be waking up to this
morning a price cap of 303
549 pounds announced by you this morning
a historic rise in energy prices people
might be asking
what's the point of off gem if it can't
protect its consumers
well look i talk to customers
all the time and i know that for many
many people this will be devastating
news this morning but let me explain
what's happening in the market and
what's driving the changes that we're
seeing
so after covid last year we saw lots of
economies grow particularly asia and
that already put pressure on the gas
market and as we saw prices began to
spike in around september of last year
now this year over and above that we
have seen a slow and deliberate cut-off
of gas by russia to the european market
and that has made prices spike much much
further when i look at the prices for
winter now for buying the gas they are
15 times what they normally are now that
would happen in petrol that would mean
it would cost us 400 to 500 pounds to
fill our car so ultimately the cost of
energy is changing dramatically and
that's why the price cap needs to change
and that's why we are announcing the
incredibly difficult news that it's
going up to
3549 pounds today
and yet if you look at the off chairman
website it does say that your role is to
protect consumers by working to deliver
a fairer energy system
but when you hear national energy action
predicting that 8.2 million people will
be in fuel poverty
from october people will feel that
consumers aren't being protected
well look what we are also saying today
is that the regulator has done
everything that it can the price cap was
designed principally to do one thing and
that was to stop those retail companies
charging unfair profits over and above
the cost of the energy they need to buy
and those profits are around zero in the
market today but what we can't do is
force companies to buy energy for less
than it costs because ultimately they
won't be able to afford to buy the
energy that we need what we're saying
today though is this is a big problem
this is a big problem for customers now
in 10 days time we will have a new
administration a new prime minister and
a new set of ministers and what we are
saying to them today is we will need to
work with you and the industry and ngos
and there will need to be urgent and
decisive action to tackle this problem
because the difficult news we have today
is that when i look out to winter and i
look out to next year there is continued
significant increasing price pressure so
we all need to work together but i am
confident that if we do so we will get
through this for customers but that will
mean urgent and decisive action from the
government
what should that urgent and decisive
action look like do you think
well we are working very very closely
with officials to make sure there are
big choices available to ministers and
the prime minister and the new
ministerial team now it's not my place
as a regulator to lay those plans out
that needs to be done rightly by elected
politicians but we are all working very
hard to make sure there are clear
choices available for the new team in 10
days time we will work with government
as we are doing today we will work with
the industry and ngos as we are doing
today but this does need further
intervention remember when prices
increased before government did act
government did put together a support
package what we are saying is given
these changes all of that support needs
needs to change and we do need
intervention that is urgent and decisive
in government to make sure that
customers are looked after this winter
we will play our part but a regulator
the industry and the ngos on their own
won't fix this we need to do this with
the government
do you think the system needs to change
is the energy price cap fit for purpose
anymore when it rises so steeply so
often
well look the price cap was designed to
do one thing and that was to make sure
that those retail companies aren't
charging what they used to charge they
used to charge up to six even nine
percent above the level that you're
seeing today imagine that added on top
of the bills that we are talking about
today what it can't do though is
subsidize the cost of energy that does
need to be paid for through the market
at the moment what we do need to do is
work with the government work with ngos
work with everyone to make sure that we
can tackle this i am confident that
customers will get through this this
winter but we do need to work together
urgently and decisively to make that
happen
there's a lot to do but i'm confident
that working together we can do this
apologies for interrupting i mean the
way that the price cap is working at the
moment
looks like it's protecting the companies
the energy companies at the expense of
the consumer
can you see how it's perceived to look
like perceived to be like that is that
how you say it
look if i can understand why everyone
today is feeling frustrated incredibly
worried and probably incredibly angry
but the price cap has to reflect the
legitimate cost in the market now when i
look at what's happening with the gas
market when i look frankly at what is
being caused by the russian shutdown of
gas to europe the costs are there they
are massively increasing and that does
need to be reflected in the price cap
but what we're not doing today which we
used to do five or six years ago is
adding big profits for the retail
companies on top of that so it is doing
its job but all of us need to work
together to do more to make sure
customers are protected and to make sure
ultimately economically and for
customers we get through this this
winter and beyond
but is the customer being put first here
given that
the way that the announcement is made it
used to be twice a year we're now going
to get it every three months there'll be
another announcement of another rise in
january just when people are going
through a winter and having to use more
energy that the consumer's needs are not
being thought through here are they
well we focus absolutely on consumer
needs but we all have to accept as we
saw last year when companies fail
ultimately those costs fall back on
consumers so when we make our decisions
we make them thinking only about what
cost falls on customers and how we best
look after customers now in this case
the price cap does need to change to
adapt to a more volatile market but
ultimately we need to work with
government because we accept that what
is there right now is not going to be
enough to deal with the situation we're
facing this winter and that's really why
we are saying there is a collective
effort here that needs to be made the
regulator cannot change this on our own
the industry cannot change on its own
the ngos cannot change it on their own
but with government working with the new
administration and the new ministerial
team we can get ahead of this and make
sure that customers are genuinely looked
after this winter it's really important
that we see what is coming and i accept
today's rise is a big shock for many
families and we work together to tackle
it that's why we're asking the
government the new government when it's
in place in 10 days time to act urgently
and decisively to make sure that we do
offset the impacts not just for
customers but for the economy as a whole
yesterday we saw a folk forecast for the
energy price cap
to rise by next april to over six
thousand pounds six thousand eight
hundred and three pounds was the
forecast is that the kind of reality we
have to face next year
well i would treat any
forecast for april with a huge amount of
caution i've seen the forecast even for
october although they were very accurate
a few weeks ago they were not accurate a
few months ago so i wouldn't hold on to
any particular figure but as i've said
when i look into the market
it is possible and i emphasize this it
is possible that
there is for example peace in russia and
ukraine this whole thing unwinds and
prices may stabilize or fall but it is
much much more likely that prices
continue to rise and what i wouldn't do
and what i caution anyone against doing
is saying what that figure would be for
next april it simply is incredible at
this stage but yes there is a big
challenge ahead of us this winter that's
why all the agencies that are involved
need to work together to act urgently
and decisively to make sure that we can
tackle this so today off-gem is saying
we need to work with others to tackle
this for customers
is it true that you're working on plans
to offer discounts to people who cut
down their energy usage at peak times
and if so how would that work
well look there was a great scheme run
by part of national grid and one of the
energy companies that does say if we
move our power so if you remember you
know the highest demand for power is
usually
early in the morning when we're waking
up we're having our breakfast and
it's sort of five or six at night when
many of us are cooking and many of us
are getting home now if we can shift
that power we can massively reduce the
needs of the system and what we are
saying with that scheme is that if you
do move your pack if you do move your
the time you use your energy
you should get some money back so i
think that's a great scheme that may
well help this winter but a great scheme
we should look to for the future because
the more we can change things like that
the more we will make the whole system
cost manageable and the whole system
costs come down and look the way the
country will get out of this situation
ultimately is to reduce our dependence
on the international gas market create
more homegrown energy and build on the
sorts of schemes that allow us allow us
to choose when we use our energy and
indeed get discounts if we're able to
move it away from those peaks the future
is really clear what we've got to do is
work to help customers through this
winter
okay well jonathan really
ceo of gem thanks very much indeed your
time this morning
thank you